the thing is that
all right I had a friend who
was a bartender at this bar right and
I'm talking to him and he he was on
steroids at one point and put on like 40
pounds of muscle or whatever and I was
under the impression because I've been
actually believing women my whole life
that women weren't into that kind of
thing and I'm like so when you were
super advantic
did you get like less attention from
girls he's like what he's like bro it's
like I had a sign on my forehead saying
sick because every single girl that
would look at me you know if it like and
I'm sure you probably are not super
attracted to like a guy that's like
massive steroid looking at it right I
would assume you as an average woman
you're probably but at the end of the
day those dudes are getting attention in
a way where that even if a small
percentage of those women convert into
sex partners those dudes are getting so
much more sex as a result of looking
like this total freak than a normal guy
even though the a normal woman would
tell you that she wants a normal guy